so what was it like for you working
opposite Kelsey Grammer because he's
just so fun as the bad guy in this you a
gambling man Jack not anymore
once Camping man always a gambling man
here's a little backstory with that my
mom and I the first show that that we
ever really watched together I just
become old enough to watch tears with
her so Thursday nights we would watch
tears together then we would watch
Frasier together now her favorite actor
bar none no one comes close like no one
could even hold a flame to Kelsey
Grammer in my mom's eyes so fast-forward
a few years and my mom was diagnosed
with cancer she was going through chemo
and we would be down there and she would
say I just want to go home watch Frasier
like right that's what we're gonna do it
was such a great experience he's so much
fun and he was so much fun especially
with some of his dialogue yeah that's
what I think is going to shock people
when they hear some of the stuff that
falls out of his face in this movie this
is just really find a vibe and you
kicked ass in this Thanks yeah I mean
that was part of what I really loved
about the script is that it was fun
it didn't take itself too seriously or
anything you know is just fun action
movie just forget about everything
that's happening now even if it's just
for our bullet-proof Casino in the sky
by any government agency or it is they
carry out to a billion on board crypto
and millions in cash you and your crew
to take down the house generally any
role that I end up taking I know at some
point physicality is gonna be involved
because having been a wrestler for 28
years now it's my wheelhouse right so I
always assume when I get a script
there's going to be some fight scenes or
some kind of action scenes and I think
any director realizes pretty quickly I'm
like a kid in a candy store at that
point I'm like ooh oh okay all right
well let's try this so I sit down with
the stunt coordinators and they love it
because they can just show me once and
it's like okay we got it and then we run
through it with money plane only had one
fight scene but it was fight scene in a
cockpit so you get me who six four he's
66 in a cockpit and it was like two
gorillas